and he's like I've seen problems that
don't exist in white communities that
exist in Black communities and I don't
want to be I just want to go as far away
as possible [__] dude yeah Salt Lake
City doesn't have that many black people
uh maybe don't help his side of the
thing
[Music]
do you guys remember the comic strip uh
Dilbert oh yeah you've seen what's been
going on with that no it's pretty heavy
man it's pretty crazy Dilbert the comic
strip the office guy got canceled right
yeah I mean they took his comic off
about every newspaper Adam Scott Adams
Even though it's not like so what it's
out of the newspaper
have to check the newspaper out of our
Lives ages ago I didn't even know they
existed still no I didn't either but
yeah big whoop but the main thing is
what he said was pretty uh what'd he say
so um he went on this rant it was a good
rant too
yeah you watched it yeah I saw the clip
yeah it was a very you're like oh this
guy it's a very out of his mind oh it's
a long rant oh yeah yeah I mean it's it
the the ramp that you're seeing like
posted on social media is like a the
rest of it's like pretty good but um
what do you mean pretty good like pretty
pretty sizable pretty size a lot a lot
okay meaning he makes a lot of sense but
then the bangers his his singles are the
ones that are going out you gotta hit
single very little interludes but yeah
he basically said uh he started going
off about he was citing this one survey
that was done that showed that over 50
of black people are not okay with white
people that's what he equated to like
the thing asks
um the statement it's okay to be white
do you have a do you agree with that or
not that's basically what the question
was in the survey and over 50 of people
uh it's not true that it was over 50
it's like it was something like 20
something percent said no and then the
20-something percent said I don't have
an answer or they weren't willing to
what the [__] kind of question is that
yeah that's a setup are you okay being
Asian it's okay to be white why like
well the right answer is no which it's
not okay to be white obviously it
literally says do you agree with the
statement it's okay to be white that's
the question
and uh what do you guys think what do
you think a majority let's just say a
majority of the black people that
answered it did not have a positive
answer agreeing to it let's say that
yeah so he was citing that and saying
like uh like I've stood up for uh
different causes for black people for a
really long time and he's like there's
no fixing this he's like if that's what
they think then that is a hate group
like you cannot
you can't vote that direction in that
size I think it's a thousand people they
asked and he's like I he would say my
best advice is just to get as far away
from black people as possible get the
[__] out get the [__] away oh dang yeah
and he's like I've seen problems that
don't exist in white communities that
exist in Black communities and I don't
want to be I just want to go as far away
as possible oh [__] dude yeah Salt Lake
City doesn't have that many black people
uh maybe don't help his side of the
thing because he's if he's he's talking
about like if I is this guy in L.A
because I mean like I just think
everyone that's in entertainment doing
comic books and everything they're like
all living in La I'm like if you don't
like diversity bro like La is not the
place for you I don't know if he's from
La oh okay is it wrong for him to not
want to be diverse like if that's his
own personal opinion like what do you
guys think I think it's not wrong but I
think at the same time if you speak on
behalf of like a credible newspaper or
like you know what I mean you represent
something that you don't just represent
your own voice anymore and I think you
need to be conscious of that you think
dilberg's racist
do you think he's racist bro I don't
know the cartoon maybe he might be you
know what I'm saying like anytime you're
like truly especially from a public
awareness point of view you don't just
represent your own voice anymore you
represent like you know everything that
is uh yeah you know so you got to be
cautious I I read his book called uh
think bigly yeah I think it was called
think bigly it was interesting but he
was dissecting the Trump campaign and
all that stuff and um
so I think he became a pretty hardcore
open Trump supporter and you think you
start the capital
trip I think um where it started for him
you know in Hollywood if you are a
Republican or if you are like right wing
you're basically the devil right so then
I think for him
that was his first journey of like yo
why can't I just be
like Republican or whatever something
like that I think and it's like why
can't in America you just be one
political party or the other why you
gotta be painted as like a a horrible
human being do you think he wants to
represent white pride
he's like well black people could have
pride I don't know man I'll be proud of
my race why does it sound so weird when
when someone white wants to live around
white people but like Asians do that a
lot I think it's just the context I
think it sounds weird
to people that have a weird view on
racism because that doesn't sound weird
to me it doesn't sound weird to me
either like if you want to I'm like if
you want to live with like-minded like
similar light-skinned digital
lifestyle a bunch of round eye I'm like
oh yeah like like Salt Lake City go go
live over there
he's trying to offer a solution right
but it's obviously not gonna fix racism
but for him his action also doesn't lead
to more racism if you think about it
because he's just like let me just
bounce like because he wants it I don't
know because the thing is
okay so so like if he was an immigrant
and he wanted to kind of he misses his
like let's say [__] Polish sausages
or some [__] right and he's like man
where my polish is at like I need to go
find my [__] Polish Village
so he could get whatever and then he can
be into the culture but if he's like
white white like American where he's
like just basically like he ain't
looking for that all he wants to do is
live with white folks the historical
context about that that makes it taboo
is the neighborhoods of segregation that
they created so then it just brings it
back to that where it's like this side
is white this side is and that's the
most recent memory we could think of
yeah and I think that's that touch in
our minds yeah and like like Joe said to
you when when we're talking about like
the Asian immigrants too it's like those
people don't come here speaking English
all the time so living in a community of
people that are like speaking the same
language then you build that community
in order to survive in this new land
whereas that it's like even black people
speak English so it's not like a a
crippling thing that you can be in a
community it's just based off like your
comfort which again if you're
uncomfortable with it it's not that it's
necessarily wrong as an individual point
of view but like like Joe said too I
mean that I think there is a little bit
of a hypocrisy to it especially in like
this land America wasn't owned by like
white people you know what I mean but
also though just don't go on life and
say that just kicking out just just but
he's also assuming that all of Black
America
feels this way yeah that's that's what I
thought was funny because like for me
like I'll read a buzzfeed article and I
know that that's not how people really
feel it's just how people in Silicon
Valley feel or like yeah I might read
something on Fox or Vox and know that
that's a section of America that feels a
certain way right because it's a
specific Community yeah so like there
might be a handful of like yeah let's
say like there there are black and Asian
tensions like in Oakland or something
right but like that might not be the
same in Georgia so like how you gonna
really apply a handful of people and say
all these people feel this way about me
therefore I gotta run away from them
plus plus what kind of survey is this
yeah right it's like what kind of
question is that let's ask a thousand
black people who have been triggered by
like white history in the last couple
years that's a really weird questions
it's erasmussen poll what's that
Rasmussen reports it's like a known
polling uh company right kind of
questions these days huh I know we just
have this weird obsession with the race
you know what I mean it's so [__]
weird man because no matter where the
results go it's gonna be some sort of
interesting angle that someone can take
and like run with a narrative like
that's the other thing too it's like I
don't know especially with when it's so
and the question is probably phrase in a
way where
it's like I don't want to say it meant
to be hostile but it's very easily can
be misconstrued as being like a little
like divisive I almost wish the like
Target wasn't like I would get along
like more so like like point that way
like how do we be harmonious and
everyone can turn and go this Direction
versus the way that like the media
paints it it's always like oh how are we
gonna [__] get along this constant
thing that they can milk over and over
rather than let's get to that point it's
almost like they don't want us to be
friends and build a community
together because they're gonna find out
that
we're gonna find out that they're
[__] with us and then you get guys
like this who like have been consuming
this type of stuff over a period of time
yeah the reviews could probably be very
easily skewed so they're just like
waiting to react and say crazy stuff
feels like a loaded question to me to be
like hey hey black people a thousand of
you get come over here real quick it's
okay to be white agree or disagree
I can't get a baby you know what that
makes you think of it's like that's
that's really difficult for them to
answer in the same way that if hey a
thousand elderly Asians in San Francisco
and Oakland come here real quick it's
safe to be around black people yeah like
yes you do yeah yeah really you're gonna
ask them right now in the height of
tensions and that's the only choices
they get no Nuance they have to say
either this or that you're not yeah
what's the point it doesn't seem like a
fair question to ask and then to cite
that as a source of wire moving away
like those thousand people may not be
the people that live around you and
you're this dot like you're not moving
away from this is for a Salt Lake City
dude another thing that this dude did
that like why he [__] up though is
like it doesn't matter the opinion of
being right or wrong especially if it's
his own opinion but I think when you
take like a pull of a thousand and even
if like over 50 are like negative in
some way in your eyes or whatever
like what he did was also strike out
like all hope like there's no chances I
mean he said that verbally he's like
there's no fixing yeah and I think
that's that's also just like uh an issue
with it if you're that's like looking at
a problem being like unsolvable you know
what I mean and that's like not
necessarily the way that
um communicates best to a broad uh like
oh yeah demographic yeah that's not what
you hit the podium yeah he's got a
Podium yeah not just white people listen
to it so it's kind of like yo you gotta
think about that you know what I'm
saying you can't take out a hundred
percent of the hope and with them with
him I don't like that statement that he
had of um I've done so much already for
the black community and this is the
thanks I get like that's how it came off
as right yeah that's kind of what he
said yeah if you're if okay so if you're
really genuinely trying to
um do things out of Goodwill you wanna
make the communities like come together
all this stuff right then in my opinion
the mission wasn't accomplished until
the sentiment is gone so then like it's
not up to you how much effort you put in
and when you're finished it's actually
when the mission is completed is when
the work was done so then also like
people are gonna have different
experiences right so like I can do as
much work as I can to try to heal a
community but there's gonna be other
people that are getting bullied by
Asians or whatever is going on that'll
have different experiences and I'm like
but I did almost all this [__] work
for 20 years but it's like yeah but
we're you're right it should have been
gone by now yeah man you have so much
for us thank you
that's that's experienced something
completely different never met me right
so it's like because I mean one one
thing that I can relate to is like Japan
and Korean relations right I'm Japanese
American I don't [__] have a
connection to this but every time that
talk comes to play people that are angry
about it they just care that your DNA is
Japanese yeah right so then they're like
oh you know
colonizer DNA or whatever like your
country this and that I'm like I wasn't
even born there bro but then for I think
in those situations
it's so so much um heartache that
they're blind to the differences they
can't see that like you know this is an
American this is completely different
but like you should still feel what we
felt and all and I'm like okay cool if
that's what it takes to kind of like
create an olive branch and then just be
like hey like what you know what's going
on what's the what's the issue here like
can we change perspectives in like real
life face to face then imaginary like
your peoples this way so I'm like
um basically there's generational crazy
[__] that's going down with angry like
people right like because of what
they're what they've been told what
their family members experience and you
can
kind of have examples of this of every
single ethnic group
some people went through genocides
holocausts whatever right so there's
tension between all of these groups but
I think his method of just running away
makes it extremely so much more [__]
worse yeah I blame the [__] poll
that's a dumbass question that's a
stupid which is all bad bro it's all bad
[Music]
foreign